- [Narrator] What was once a thick wall
built to protect one of
Hungary's grandest castles
has been transformed into a lookout
with the most beautiful and
panoramic views of Budapest.
(lively music)
The Fisherman's Bastion
is a 500-foot-long lookout
located on the bank of the Danube River,
and is one of the most visited
sites in all of Budapest.
The site is only around
a hundred years old,
and was built in celebration
of the 1,000th birthday
of the Hungarian state.
The neo-Romanesque
medieval-style architecture
reflects the era the
first Hungarian king ruled
in the year 1,000.
The Bastion's most distinguishing features
are the seven turrets representing
the seven Hungarian tribes who founded
the present-day country in the year 895.
The name, Fisherman's Bastion,
honors the guild of fisherman
who protected the castle
from being destroyed
during the Middle Ages from enemies.
The intention in its construction
was to create a landmark
that would showcase
Budapest's gorgeous views.
Their success is evident, as
Fisherman's Bastion's archways,
windows, and wide communal stairways
provide a view unlike any
other in all of Budapest.